okay leute ein kurze periode bis zu 33%
ihr beide seid mega offen blieb offen
[Musik]
willkommen beim ein video
ich weiß meine haare
ich muss trinken ganz dringend ganz ganz
dringend ich glaube so dringend muss ich
noch nie zum friseur
weil es sieht aus wie so ein vogel ist
ja irgendwie hatte ich in letzter zeit
also zumindest den letzten drei tagen
will ich gar keine zeit deswegen kam
auch kein video heute gehts aber ähnlich
wie dann die durch bei mega beschäftigt
mit meinen klausuren heute morgen habe
ich zum beispiel noch meine mathe
klausur geschrieben
ich denke so von 90 punkten sollte ich
15 erreicht haben also ohne spaß
das war die schlimmste klausur meines
lebens mit ups und arbeitet eigentlich
scheißegal zu gute kommen zu einem neuen
in bayern neuen video ich hab schon fast
verlernt fällt der ball ein video und
hab ich ja ungefähr vor zwei wochen die
fidor ausbauen wo ich so ein fest
gemacht habe wie gut kenne ich alex oder
wie bekenne ich halte mich selber und
ich hab euch da aufgefordert wie immer
weitere quizzes zuzusenden das habt ihr
auch wirklich nichts gemacht und ich
habe mir ein paar rausgesucht und waren
sich ich brauche eine neue freundin oder
sind ja ganz klar
und ja darauf habe ich mich heute mal
ein bisschen spezialisiert was ich kurz
sofort los geht auf jeden fall loswerden
muss und zwar für alle die aus berlin
kommen oder aus der umgebung davon
berlin berlin ist für mich vor
oder wenn er die chance hat nach berlin
zu kommen ich bin am samstag auf der you
messe also diesen samstag achter sind da
ist schon in drei tagen kommt auf jeden
fall rom wirklich kommt vorbei weil er
wir können natürlich mega cool photos
lagern können bisher labern und so
weiter und ich werde an diesem tag noch
vom zdf begleitet
deswegen kommt vorbei vielleicht seid
ihr dann auch im fernsehen also achter
sind da alex w in berlin kommt vom ok
genug gelagert ihr seid teil von mir
gewohnt wir fangen jetzt an
okay ich bin gespannt ich bin sehr
nervös weil vielleicht welcher gleich
meine traumfrau aussehen
okay man gibt dir welcher frauen zu
passt zu dir
ich habe mir gedacht ich muss erstmal
wichtiger auf den geschmack kommen
gucken was möchte ich so was stelle ich
mir vor
und deswegen erstmal die risk wird und
dann habe ich noch ein wirklich sehr
sehr ausführliches class bekommen dazu
alex bitte du muss man herausfinden
welche youtube hinzu gepackt und ganz
vielleicht die das ja dann vielleicht
diese youtube drin und meldet sich beim
fangen einfach an also wie sollte deine
traumfrau sein verführerisch sexy
versorgt erfahrenen alten also das
richtige passende ist da jetzt nicht
dabei ich nehme einfach mal welcher
dieser orte spricht ich am meisten an
ein welche kranke person hat die vierte
eine ausstellung über andy warhol mit
früchten schwimmbad an wie soll ich
seine traumfrau auf keinen fall seien
langweilig verklemmt zu stickig versaut
auf keinen fall langweilig was findest
du von den folgenden ding an einer frau
äußerlich am meisten sexy große brüste
groß dahinter zahnspange brille kräftige
oberschenkel ausfallende frisur steht
wurzel rehaugen kleine feine hände also
ich würde jetzt sagen gar nicht
natürlich so ein paar punkte davon ich
nehme es einfach mal ohne euch zu zeigen
dass hier welche musik hörst du gerne
metal rock cafe topf an gar nichts davon
pop und country pop punk nehmer passt am
ehesten welche dieser körperteil am
weiblichen körper findest du am meisten
sex die beine augen braucht nase
du hast aber ne geile nase brauchen wir
einfach mal was leute sie zu sein vor
hallo ihr macht mich jetzt schon
ohne spaß was hat für kranke fatima dass
er habe ihr macht mich jetzt von volker
lösch in freundin von meinem freund sind
auch meine freunde was geht ab lässt
sich sehr gut an
wie sollte sie im bett sein und sonst
was ist hier in einer beziehung wichtig
wir sollten gemeinsame hobbys pflegen
auf jeden fall
jürgen ich will diese basieren aber wir
sollten gemeinsam häufig link so und nun
noch die letzte frage welcher dieser
fälle im feld die am besten entfernt ist
echt rüber draußen zu 40 prozent sind
sie du steht auf bett gehört in
hemmungsloses frech und sehr
verführerische frauen bewirkt eine frau
die sehr an offenbar bist du nicht auch
eine tiefere beziehung das ziemlich
jetzt aber gemein von dem ich dachte da
kommt raus dass wir so ein bisschen so
einen positiven anstoß gibt offenbar
bist du dich auf eine tiefere beziehung
aus sie hätten noch das folgende werden
können zu 40 prozent sind sie zu dir
wird am besten eine sport fanatikerin
passen du brauchst eine frau die immer
in bewegung ist und mit ihr zusammen
sport trägt sportlich frauen sind sehr
unausgeglichen und bei ihnen muss immer
etwas am laufen seien
so wird die bestimmte nie langweilig und
wieder wird man das dann nicht als er
das volksleiden ich meine das sind ja
auch 40
so leute da ich ja jetzt schon weiß
welche frau am besten zu mir passen
würde oder wie diese frau sein muss muss
ich jetzt noch ermitteln welche frau das
ist und den besten fall ist natürlich
eine youtube welcher charakter trifft am
besten auch nicht zu verrückt und 70 und
west auf jeden fall stellte besseres da
man sich den rest ganz lesen nicht
betragen
ach das ehrt einen klamotten style schön
und letztlich modernen tropfen und schön
und letztlich was hast du für eine
schlechte seite
ich bin nicht immer 50 sinkt so gerne
bzw oft ja aber nicht gerne in der
öffentlichkeit bist du oft in anderen
ländern bzw kontinenten in anderen
ländern oft ich überlege mir das immer
spontan schlägst du dich oft wie ich
denke ich gar nicht kann ich aber nicht
ausziehen
auf jeden fall kommt auch an der auch
die verlust ich habe sehr oft die
flüssigkeit kommt drauf an würde ich mal
gesagt bist du eher groß oder klein
mittel groß würde ich mal sagen was ist
für dich am wichtigsten
familie und freunde ehrlichkeit und
abenteuer spaß und freundschaft gar
nicht weit und abenteuer sich immer gut
an was hast du für ein talent ich bin
auf jeden fall sehr spontan
es ist zwar kein talent aber es findet
der eigenschaft und ich finde
spontaneität ist eigentlich das aller
aller aller wichtigste weiter die total
um spontane mit denen kann ich
eigentlich gar nichts anfangen was
hältst du von dir selbst warten so wie
ich bin ein bisschen verrückt sein
schadet niemals deutschland mich niemals
aggressiv machen hören nie drauf was
andere über dich sagen das ist auf jeden
fall wichtig und das habe ich so was
folge lernt ja nie drauf was andere über
mich sagen weil über mich wird natürlich
sehr sehr viel rede auch nicht immer im
positiven sinne
aber mittlerweile ist mir scheißegal was
denken andere über dich selbst und
hilfsbereit und schönes es ein bisschen
auch dann würde ich dieses unschöne
anklicken
hübsche und cool er ich werde einfach
mal sagen selbstbewusst und hilfsbereit
trifft es ganz gut hat so ein zeug lege
ich dachte jetzt r und welche youtube
hin zu mir passt es sollte ermitteln was
hat das jetzt hast du glaub ich ein
freund also ich hab schon freunde aber
ich suche eine perfekte youtube erinnert
sich doch gar nichts nachstehen hast du
eine freundin schon seit längerem nicht
mehr
seit kurzem nicht mehr fuchs du am
meisten auf youtube keine festen format
ich gucke eigentlich eher wenig was
würdest du hauptsächlich dürfe videos
hochladen
ja es macht auf jeden fall das worauf
ich bock habt deswegen kommt auch gerade
wahrscheinlich dieses video einfach
drauf bock hab ich könnte auch was
machen
nur ich haben seit einfach der auftakt
deswegen mache ich also sitzt halt
meistens wirklich so ich weiß ich möchte
über brauchen zum beispiel auch wieder
hochladen
ich habe aber noch keine ahnung was es
ist und ich weiß auch dass ich
vielleicht morgen abend auch noch keine
ahnung haben werde aber übermorgen
wieder kommt das ist mir ganz spontan
immer okay jetzt kommen wir langsam am
ende mehr
die letzte frage laute zum schluss was
sollten youtuber für dich sein humorvoll
und lustig hübsche und süßes und cola
bergmann und lustig auf jeden fall das
ist das art auf youtube und ich glaube
viele von euch schauen mich auch weil
sie meinen humor ganz gut finden heißt
es eigentlich dortmund oder hier nase
wert verstanden haben die kommentare
sind okay leute ein kurzen trommelwirbel
kurz einblenden
youtube passt zu 33 prozent ihr beide
seiten offen blieb und offen aber den
schönen frauen war jetzt alles umsonst
oder was also melina falls du das siehst
vielleicht möchtest du dir es ja noch
mal anders überlegen
ich bin alex zu meinen eigenschaften ich
bin sehr sportlich ist es so gerne ich
mache auch leidenschaftlich gerne
youtube-videos und mache auch die
verrücktesten dinge mit meinen hafens
meine handynummer ist 0 1 5146 24
[Musik]
und ich bin jetzt eigentlich ein
bisschen enttäuscht schreibt mir doch
einfach mal in die kommentare wer würde
eure meinung nach gut zu ihr passen okay
leute sowie dazu also kommt auf jeden
jeden jeden jeden fall samstag nach
berlin auf die you can make pictures and
talk to recover zeigt auf jeden fall
snapshot und instagram alle infos zu der
ju sind auch und in der video
beschreibung und wir sehen uns dann am
freitag wieder
ich wünsche euch noch eine angenehme
woche haut rein